M it's
God it's
God I got one last question one last I
wanted to show you something I wasn't
done with
you so look remember we talking about
prophecy right okay look I'm going to
show you dang
win sorry I want to show you this surely
he has borne our griefs and carried our
sorrows yet we esteemed him stricken
Smitten by God and Afflicted he was
wounded for our transgressions he was
bruised for our iniquities the
chastisement for our peace was upon Him
meaning he was punished for our place
and by his stripes we are healed all we
like sheep have gone astray we have
turned everyone to his own way and the
lord has laid on him the iniquity the
sin of us all who does that sound like
to you well that's how you yeah they're
talking about Jesus Christ AB now here's
the important part about this this was
written
700 years before Jesus okay you can say
that right it's another thing to believe
it but you can say that we have it check
the Desy Scrolls okay you can pull up on
your phone yeah yeah pull it up okay
let's let's let's just say that what
you're saying is true yes right bottom
line that's still is still recording but
the even okay let's say that's true
right everything you're saying is true
let's just go ahead and say that yeah
that's still that's still a word of man
saying that that no it's the word of God
see look yeah it's the word of God
through a man okay I see what you're
saying so there's nothing wrong with
that yeah but that but that's based on
the belief that that the person believes
that God spoke to that person so like
this is what you have to do cuz remember
we're not talking about blindness we're
talking about objective truth right
following the evidence where it leads so
if if in if 700 years before Jesus is
born we have a pro somebody named Isaiah
writing something that clearly describes
what happens to Jesus way before it
happens how do you explain that other
than prophecy oh because obviously God
can give a person the power to see into
the future boom yeah that that's that
that's not farfetched but what I'm
saying is if if you look at the logic
right think about it this way that would
mean that he's the true God no no no
wait let let me let me just explain it
this way like I said like I was telling
this guy too even before the Quran and
even before the Bible even before Jesus
Christ happen thean don't got nothing
like that yeah okay either way both but
either way I'm just let you know before
those even Jesus Christ came into the
world 2,000 years ago right obviously he
did exist before he came into I'm going
to go ahead and accept that as well but
at the when you this this is the cors of
it for me that's the correct right
because for me God is the one true
Mighty God creator I see a creation
there's a Creator right yeah but you
don't know who that is that it what do
you mean I don't know who it is because
when I'm asking you to identify this God
as a monotheist it's the spirit of it's
the spirit who is that the universal
father who how do you know wait how do
you know wait stop stop stop stop how do
you know that he's a father well because
he's the Creator you can look at okay
he's the it it's just it's it's just
verbage I could I could just say like
for
example for you're right for example in
the Quran they believe in the one
Creator as well they reject that he's a
father okay yeah you get what I'm saying
so how do you know if he's a father or
not but that doesn't matter the matter
it does matter because it's telling you
I'm asking you who is your god the one
toighty God creator how do you know who
that is you're just telling me it's a my
mighty Creator fine I believe in the
almighty Creator are we talking about
the same person well when I say that I
accept cuz I say I hear other people
saying this they accept Jesus Christ as
Lord savior like the Jehovah Witnesses
and Mormons and other and other
Christians I I say this not Christians
or whoever the point is that that's what
they say but I say this I accept the one
true almighty God creator as my Lord
andv but you don't though because you
reject who he is and you reject his
Revelation okay okay but that's based on
on the belief of of people no I'm asking
what's your name brother oh Jorge Jorge
yeah sohe when you look at that and you
acknowledge that God can reveal
something and and and give a give
somebody information of the future only
God can do that right yeah okay so if
God did that and we have the evidence
that he did we know who the God is well
people can TW that's the reason I say
that people themselves uh can twist
things but how can we twist that if it
existed 700 years prior no I I okay
you're so you're seeing that Jesus
Christ took all the iniquities of the
sins of people and he he di okay yeah
and even you know that even though you
don't believe that that's the story L
that's the story line how does that
story line exist 700 years prior to the
fact that that that because there was a
prophet who conceed into the future by
the power of God so that would mean that
God the true God revealed that he has
the son the Messiah who also has his
divine nature who's going to take on the
sins of the world and he revealed that
to a man who wrote it down so that you
can know today that he revealed himself
you have no excuse I I I get what you're
saying and and I see where your point of
view is but it's like it's like it's
like seeing something and like just like
two people seeing something I see it I
see what you're saying and and that's
possible and it could happen and it did
happen but the perspective of the man
who wrote that right it's not his
perspective how remember he can't know
this outside of God saying look man this
is what's about to God's showing him
that he could yeah he could see it but
then he puts his twist to it is what I'm
saying what twist that that's the reason
he died Jesus Christ according to his
words he died to prove to people that
there's life after death no not not just
after death but that there's life in him
after death so like you the only way
that you but look the only way that you
have life after death is if you're in
him in Christ in the Messiah outside of
that you don't have you're you're going
to be dead for eternity but but when you
but the L I said is that you can't you
can't change the logic because even
before he came into the that's the
reason I say even before either of these
Muhammad or the prophets or Jesus Christ
came into the picture there was
thousands of years of human existence so
all right so those humans needed
salvation yeah okay let's start there
which means they looked at the reality
there's no books there's no Jesus
there's no prophets they they look up
into the sky and say well some of them
might have logically thought well there
probably a Creator right let's make they
probably pray to God right they're not
going to know all the things that you
know in accordance to whatever text you
want want to bring into the conversation
but there was Revelation back then still
okay yeah but every but you can't that's
the thing you keep pining it on
Revelations now even talking about the
book I'm talking about God's revelation
okay but the automatic Revelation the
one that's constant every day is that
the fact that there's a creation there's
a Creator y right that that you don't
need anybody to tell you that that's
just a fact so then when these other
people start now worshiping Idols that's
on them right yeah that's on them
because if they worship by hour or
another deity whatever so so this is
what we call General Revelation and then
there's special Revelations there
General Revelation where God reveals to
all mankind that he is God and that's
who he is he's the Creator no Idols no
none right and then there's the special
Revelation where he reveals himself
through his word that I am who I am it's
me and that that well that word that he
reveals himself through which is through
prophets whether it be Jesus Christ or
Muhammad or whoever wasn't Muhammad okay
whoever the point is that those those um
Revelations or
prophets they can't be trusted you can't
trust people you can't trust people this
this is what I'm asking exactly since
you can't trust people yeah how was it
that Isaiah was supposed was supposed to
accurately and in detail tell us exactly
what happens to Jesus 700 years before
he seeing into the future is possible
that's possible by the so then that
means he's not lying right then you see
that you're taking the power that he
sees it's like for instance if I saw you
10 days from now you win the lottery
right let's say let's say that you that
happens right let's just bring guess
right no no no let's say that God gives
you the power and a year from now you
win the lottery right and I I I see
frame right but then I put my
interpretation to it that oh he won the
lottery because of whatever reason I
want to put add to it seeing something
in the future doesn't necessarily imply
whatever it is it's written just cuz he
has the power of foresight doesn't
necessarily mean it's like well Jesus
you believe Jesus was the real person
right yes Jesus Christ existed and you
believe he was crucified under Pontius
pilot right yeah he he was crucified
okay so how in the world he did
resurrect yes Lord have mercy no no he
did all that but it's that the twist
that they're putting what twist that
that he died for people's sins he that's
already revealed no but that's what that
revealed by who by God no that you're
saying God but but know even you say God
no I God G God gave him the power to do
the thing so God gave him the Revelation
that Jesus was going to die for the
atonement of the sins of the world no
dude he there's no way that no because
you mean there's no way what there's no
way that a human being can can be paying
for the sins of other people everybody
has to up the beautiful Point there's no
way that a human being can go ahead and
atone for the sins of the world right
listen to this and he was a human being
hey what does what does it say he's not
God what does it say but it says that
Jesus is God oh it says Jesus Is God let
me show you something because not a mere
human being cannot atone for the sins of
the world it would have to be God
himself which is why this is this Jesus
Is God because he had the ability to
take on the sin say it with me for of
the
world but he was a human being you can't
he was more than that brother okay yeah
look look let me show you let me look
look look look I'm about to show you
this man look is that is that that's the
thing you keep going to the to to the to
the the script because God is talking to
you man that ain't me but that's that
see that's a belief that you have the
scripture what's written there is what
it is right that's that that's the
reality yeah right you believe it no
well I believe some of it because
obviously it happened right Jesus Christ
did resurrect
watch this look but the the
interpretation of it is what I'm saying
interpretation different it's Revelation
bro look look look just look okay for
unto us a child is born human right yes
okay unto us a son is given a human boy
yes all right cool it says hold on it
says upon Him upon his shoulder yes will
be the government yeah and his name
Shall be Called wonderful counselor read
that for me it says Mighty God Mighty
God Everlasting Everlasting father
Prince of Peace so you mean to tell me
that that the son to be born is God
himself that can you cannot that's
exactly what we're saying we're saying
that they're different distin we're
saying they're distinct persons but they
share one divine nature okay yeah but
and they each have a distinct Ro in
order to fulfill God's Divine will and
purpose okay I see what you're saying
but if but if God himself said like like
I said if he said not to worship other
gods and then you're then you're telling
people hey you worship Jesus Christ
Jesus is not another God he's another
person of the same divine nature but
when you're saying that it's two there's
two different people yeah two different
persons not two different beings so
you're you're you're confusing
personhood and being what a thing is so
being is what a thing is your nature
personhood is who a thing is okay right
there I see two trees yeah those are two
different things okay so if let's assume
that one was let's say one was God that
one tree is its own being the other tree
is its own being so you're seeing that
both of them are in the same tree yes
both of them are in the same TR they
have the same the same divine nature
there's only one Divine being right and
this one Divine being has three distinct
persons I see I see what you're saying
but that that right there for first
that's word of man but
secondly but secondly that's revelation
of God man yeah but but then it comes
back to what I was telling her uh that's
like you said that's Revelation but
before all this Revelation came into
into being there had to be salvation for
people yeah it was believing in God the
same thing believing in God and the
coming and the coming of his Redemption
okay but then then it becomes what we
what we were saying earlier why don't
you just leave it let's say ignorance is
bliss let's just say we leave it at I
love and worship the one true Mighty God
creator only I accept the one true
almighty God creat even even demons say
they believe in one God and they tremble
itan it means nothing for them okay okay
but for well that's their perception but
let's say that I believe I'm going to
say right now I accept the one God cre
is my Lord and Savior yeah okay Muslim
say the same thing whether whether it is
that what you're saying is true uh let's
just say I don't know that am I still
condemned by the Lord for not knowing
something well you're condemned for the
Lord for rejecting what came to you so
you you can't walk away today Jorge and
say I didn't know that's exactly where
this this this entire conversation leads
to right because there has to be a law
right there has to be um like what like
a consequence to not doing something
right so you're saying there's a
consequence if I don't accept Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior yeah I'm
saying that I'd rather just keep the
Lord Almighty God I know you would and
and then leave Jesus and any other
Prophet for that matter out of it I know
you would now but but unfortunately
that's not how it works now you're
saying that right no no God said that
but okay that you that's your belief
it's not about my belief it's it's the
objec of Truth it has nothing to do with
me I I showed you the objec of Truth
I showed you that God gave a revelation
even you acknowledge it as a revelation
yeah but then so what are we supposed
what are we doing well what we're doing
is because is that you're looking at it
from this timeline cuz you're you're
living in now if you lived 10,000 years
ago no brother is is that a revel what I
showed you yes was it a revelation or
not that's the word of man for me it
could be it could not yeah it sounds
like just going Circle in
circle that's all that's all it's going
he's saying the book do you have
anything else I mean compared to that
one do you have any book what you
believe no there the the the history of
humanity do we we are saying that from
the Bible do you have any book The what
you can claim it no I I'm my claim is
the reality itself because who you are
who you are it's the but you're out of
reality no but it's the history of
humanity before these things came into
being but no it started with do you
agree that Humanity starts with God it
starts with god with what God the one
true Al Mighty God who is that what God
you're appointing someone but you don't
know who you appointing to what you
pointing to yeah I'm pointing to the to
the one true almighty God creator so
okay how do you know it's not Jesus I I
cannot say that he's that it's not him
and I'm not saying that it so then why
are you rejecting it because because it
I don't want to risk the idolatry which
is what I was telling you're not risking
how are you risking idolatry if he's if
he's the one God you don't know who the
one God is you're saying that you're
you're worshiping and believing in this
one God that you are not identifying so
you're and when you say that it's not
this you you're possibly doing idolatry
right now hey that that's a possibility
but i' rather take my chances with one
true creator
than that's what we called free do do
your thing man yeah but yeah okay but
you still never answered the question of
what salvation I I answered all your I
answered all your questions for people
who didn't come who who were I answered
all your questions it's not about being
born into everybody has General
Revelation she gave you the answer we
all gave you the answer so you're so
you're just rejecting stuff and coming
up with the same questions and I'm
giving you the same answers and we're
not going anywhere yeah I I agree with
her answer your answer for me her answer
was was the best one that came out of
everybody good sck on it good stay stay
there that's all that's all we saying
faith in God uh Save By Grace that's the
one she said that was perfect and that
came to her logically
amation man you got that now so
CH even the Bible says you're saved by
faith in God and and who Revelation in
who it doesn't add that yes it does it
says it literally says that you're saved
by the grace of Christ that Christ is
your lord and savior that saves you what
do you mean it doesn't say that it says
that in the Old Testament you're saved
by faith in God it it says in it says in
the Old Testament that you're saved by
the grace of the Messiah who gave
himself for you that's what it says
there they added that afterwards all
right cool all right man all right take
care I'm going to go I'm going to I dust
my hands man I dust my
hands oh my God logic
[Music]